(electronics zap abruptly)
(dramatic music)
- Alright, first
one to finger Putin,
loser gets their butthole waxed.
I'm guessing you
have a hairy butt.
On your mark, get set, go.
(snow shoes thudding)
(audience laughs)
- [Woman] There is no hair!
- Yeah, joke's on you,
that's how I like to keep it.
Alright, whoever gets closest
to Putin's brown eye, wins.
And that winner gets to
take the loser's phone
and send one text to his ex.
(stone whooshes)
(audience laughing)
(spray can hissing)
Send it.
Saw something that
reminded me of you today.
Hope you can find the excuse to,
alright there is no way she
believes that I wrote this,
and she's typing, already
typing, that's lovely.
Alright, first one to put the
puck in Putin's pooter, wins.
Loser smokes crack.
(sticks slapping)
(pucks thudding)
Close enough, I'll smoke crack.
(sticks slapping)
(pucks thudding)
(audience applauding)
It's actually a nice, mild high.
Two silvers, one gold, not bad!
But I had to sell them because
now I'm addicted to crack.
(audience laughs)
(electronic music)